[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Come in late at night ♪
♪ When I'm alone ♪
♪ You want what's right,
but you tell me all the time ♪
♪ That I only seem
to do it wrong ♪
♪ Baby, I've got your number ♪
♪ I'll call you
when I get home ♪
♪ Now I've got
your number, baby ♪
♪ I'll never leave you alone ♪
♪ Do do ♪
♪ Do do do do do ♪
♪ Do do do do do do do do do ♪
♪ He can't jump a hurdle ♪
♪ And I can't run ♪
♪ He came by in the middle
of the night ♪
♪ Just to tell me
that I was wrong ♪
♪ Baby, I've got your number ♪
♪ I'll call you
when I get home ♪
♪ Now I've got
your number, baby ♪
♪ I'll never leave you alone ♪
♪ Do do do ♪
♪ Do do do do do ♪
♪ Do do do do do do do do ♪
♪ Do ♪
[ Applause ]
♪ Ooh ooh ooh ooh ♪
♪ Do do do do do do do ♪
♪ Do do do do
do do do ♪
♪ Maybe when things are right ♪
♪ And I feel strong ♪
♪ I'll move on to try
the things that I find ♪
♪ Only realizing
that I'm wrong ♪
♪ Baby, I've got your number ♪
♪ I'll call you
when I get home ♪
♪ Now I've got
your number, baby ♪
♪ I'll never leave you alone ♪
♪ Now I've got
your number, baby ♪
♪ I'll never leave you alone ♪
♪ Now I've got
your number, baby ♪
♪ I'll never leave you alone ♪
♪ Do do ♪
♪ Do do do do do ♪
♪ Do do do do do
do do do do do ♪
♪ Do do ♪
♪ Do do do do ♪
♪ Do do do do do ♪
♪ Do do do ♪
♪ Do do do do ♪
♪ Do ♪
♪ Oh oh oh oh oh oh oh ♪
♪ Do do do do do do ♪
♪ Do do do do do do do do ♪
♪ Do do do do do do do do do ♪
♪ Do do ♪
♪ Do do do do ♪
♪ Do do do do do do do do do ♪
♪♪
♪ Mm mm mm ♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]